we cannot run this guy we gotta reject
what we need altitude no we don't pull
the ejection handles the second I tell
you I don't want to pull the handles I
don't want to pull a handle I'm not
pulling what's wrong with this guy
they're throwing away
Egypt Egypt Egypt why are you like this
Tom
[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen your host for this
evening Jimmy Kimmel
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
thank you
give me a second adjust my danger zone
here
my banshees are caught in my inner
shearing right now all right I'm good
welcome and uh congratulations welcome
to the 95th Oscars
we made it you made it
congratulations I know that uh being
here tonight is a dream come true for
most of the people in this room thank
you for inviting me to be a part of it
especially this year when the world
finally got out of the house to see the
films you worked so hard to make the way
you intended them to be seen in a
theater
[Applause]
see that Nicole Kidman has finally been
released from that abandoned AMC
where she has been held captive for
almost two full years now it's good to
have you back Nicole
and thank you for encouraging people who
were already at the movie theater to go
to the movie theater
you look great everybody looks so great
when I look around this room I can't
help but wonder is ozempic right for me
we have so many first-time nominees here
in the acting categories alone There are
16 first-time nominees including Jamie
Lee Curtis
including Anna De armas
Colin Farrell
Michelle yeoh
Brendan Fraser
Keith we've won
all right
this is I think a great piece of Oscar
trivia 31 years ago in 1992 Brandon
Fraser and kiwi Kwan were in a movie
together remember which movie it was
Encino Man
two actors from Encino Man are nominated
for Oscars okay
what uh
what an incredible night this must be
for the two of you and what a very
difficult night for Pauly Shore
maybe it's time to reboot biodome why
not all the top 10 highest grossing
films this year were sequels or
franchises they say Hollywood is running
out of new ideas I mean poor Steven
Spielberg had to make a movie about
Steven Spielberg
congratulations Stephen look at this by
the way I want to say
right here
this is my favorite Duo of the Year
Steven Spielberg and Seth Rogen what a
pair
the Joe and Hunter Biden of Hollywood
Seth what are you on right now be honest
nothing
mushrooms right
did you give one to Stephen give him one
let's see what happens maybe he'll make
something crazy Stephen claims he's
never even smoked weed which I find hard
to believe you need to tell me you were
sober when you made a movie about an
alien who eats Reese's Pieces all day
and
can't remember how to phone home
you were high as a bike when you made
that movie
Steven is the first director to be
nominated in six different decades for
an Oscar
remarkable
as you know he is nominated for the
Fable men's which is by far his most
personal film they say write what you
know it and they say also write what you
know your mom did with her dad's best
friend and Steven did that and the
result was yet another Oscar nomination
for the great Michelle Williams who is
um
right there Michelle
and the Fable men's wasn't an easy shoot
for Michelle after almost every take
Spielberg would rush up to her with
tears in his eyes and he'd scream that's
not how mommy said it
I also want to extend congratulations to
Steven's longtime collaborator the
Maestro John Williams who is now the
oldest nominee the Oscar history
and he looks great he's
John
John turned 91 years old last month and
he's still scoring if you know what I
mean
[Applause]
and by the way uh if you've never made
love to the score from Raiders of the
Lost Ark do yourself a favor
another uh um only Walt Disney this is
great only Walt Disney has been
nominated for more Oscars than John
Williams he's been nominated 53 times
and
nominated 53 times he's won five which
honestly is not that great
but good luck tonight it was a very good
year for movies business is booming I
know people like to debate now which is
better movies or TV but here's the thing
no matter how good a show is there are
some things movies could do that TV just
can't for example a TV show can't lose a
hundred million dollars
is the gang from Babylon here they know
I was just asking if they were here I
was welcoming
at least Babylon got released in August
you know Batgirl became the first
superhero to be defeated by an
accounting department
and then we had the big one the long
long long awaited Avatar the way of
water which gave
the director the producer
Jim Cameron another opportunity to do
what he loves to do more than anything
else drowning Kate Winslet
it's the most expensive movie ever made
Disney spent two billion dollars on this
movie Just To Break Even all of Nick
Cannon's kids had to see Avatar four
times
and they did I guess James Cameron is
not here uh by the way tonight you know
you know a show is too long when even
James Cameron can't sit through it
some of the cynics are saying Jim
Cameron isn't here because he didn't get
a Best Director nomination and while I
find that very hard to believe about a
man of such deep humility he does have a
point I mean how does the academy not
nominate the guy who directed Avatar
what do they think he is a woman
what a
thank you ladies
it was some year for diversity and
inclusion we have nominees from every
corner of Dublin
five Irish actors are nominated tonight
which means the odds of another fight on
stage just went way up
and while we're on the subject of
diversity I want to say especially those
of you watching at home there are a
number of excellent films and
performances that were not nominated
tonight including till and the woman
King which are both based on true
stories with great performances from
Daniel deadweiler and Viola Davis that
are very worthy of your time if you
haven't seen them as is a small
independent film called top gun Maverick
the movie that saved the movies everyone
loved Top Gun everybody I mean
Tom Cruise with his shirt off and that
Beach football scene
L Ron hubba hubba you know what I'm
saying
[Applause]
you know Tom and James Cameron didn't
show up tonight the two guys who
insisted we go to the theater didn't
come to the theater
so if you're hoping to get a look at Tom
Cruise he's not here or or maybe he is
here maybe that's Tom Cruise right there
wearing a Judd Hirsch Mission Impossible
mask
there's only one way to find out for
sure
Judd we're going to need you to drive a
motorcycle off the roof of the theater
you know who else is here uh they write
excellent Rihanna is with us tonight
Rihanna got her first Oscar nomination
from for the song Lift Me Up from Black
Panther wakanda forever last month she
performed at the Super Bowl and Tonight
Rihanna will be performing at our
halftime in just about four and a half
hours from now
Rihanna has a nine month old backstage
and he's very cute he pooped during
rehearsal you know the last person who
pooped backstage at the Oscars was
that accountant who mixed up the
envelopes
Rihanna is Here Lady Gaga is here
wonderful
my God even Elvis is in the building
tonight there he is
convincing as Elvis still is
this is a good Hollywood Story before
they started shooting Elvis Tom Hanks
gave Austin a vintage typewriter as a
gift and in it Tom wrote he left a note
written from Colonel Tom Parker to Elvis
so then Austin used the typewriter to
write Tom back as Elvis Presley and they
got to know each other by sending
letters back and forth as Elvis and Tom
we're just going to show you how
incredibly silly this all is
have silly jobs but Austin you're so
talented I know Elvis would have loved
your performance and in fact according
to my Q Anon Reddit page he did
we know this is a special night for you
we uh want you have fun we want you to
feel safe and most importantly we want
me to feel safe so we have strict
policies in place if anyone in this
theater commits an act of violence at
any point during the show you will be
awarded the Oscar for best actor
and permitted to give a 19-minute long
speech
no but seriously the academy has a
crisis team in place if anything
unpredictable or violent happens during
the ceremony just do what you did last
year nothing
there and do absolutely nothing
maybe even give the assailant a hug
and if any of you get mad at a joke and
decide you want to come up here and get
jiggy with it
it's not going to be easy or a few of my
friends are going to have to get through
first you're going to get have to get
through the heavyweight champ Adonis
Creed before you get to me
do battle with Michelle yo before you
get to me
you are going to have to beat the
Mandalorian before you get to me
tangle with Spider-Man
you are going to have to
you were going to have to tangle with
Fable man
and then you're gonna have to go through
my right hand man Guillermo if you want
to get up to this state a way to
wait
the other Guillermo not not that not Del
Toro the yes that one okay there you go
I know he's cute but make no mistake you
even so much as wave at me that sweet
little man will beat the Lydia tar out
of you okay there will be no nonsense
tonight we have no time for shenanigans
this is a celebration of everyone here
you told us you wanted all the
categories back in and we listened
they're all back in
that's right
we will be showing all 23 categories
live tonight except for one earlier
tonight best picture went to All Quiet
on the Western Front
congratulations to Germany
we put all the categories back in
because the movie Community wanted it
almost as much as the television
Community didn't want it so no
complaining about how long the show is I
saw all your movies now it's my turn to
make you sit in the theater for three
and a half hours
that doesn't mean we don't want to hear
you speak we do we want your speeches to
be moving we also want to keep it moving
so speech goes on too long this year
we're not going to play you off stage
instead
we have a group of performers from the
movie rrr who are going to dance you off
stage